[Music]
I mean I know what stresses me out and
that is when something's gonna happen
that I'm not ready for when I don't know
what's happening I don't have the skills
necessary when when I think I'm at risk
of something but I don't know what to do
that makes me feel awful and you know
you feel nervous and and you you feel a
little bit sick and your body's giving
you all sorts of clues that you're not
ready for this thing to happen but
that's not how everybody pictures an
astronaut you know you don't picture an
astronaut sitting there all nervous and
jittery with their fingers crossed and
crying just before a large and we're not
because even though it's dangerous we
are ready we have practiced we have
trained we have worked for years to
actually look at what are the risks what
are the dangers what are they going to
look like how can we minimize them and
how are we going to respond to them and
then we've practiced them over and over
and over again so that instead of just
being nervous or stressed we are ready
and the best antidote for stress is
competence becoming competent if you're
good at this thing then you no longer
just have to be worried and afraid of it
though don't allow yourself because I
think stress is an awful way to go
through life gives you an ulcer you feel
bad you're you're you're dreading
something happening in your own life
instead if you possibly can try and
figure out why is my body giving me all
these clues why is it saying I dread
this thing why am I not ready for this
thing that's about to happen and then
instead of just sitting there feeling
sick say okay I've got six hours to this
things happen this thing happens let's
use these six hours to change my
capability to improve my readiness to
deal with this you know if I knew that
the person next to me was gonna have a
heart attack in 20 minutes I could use
20 minutes to become way more prepared
for that heart attack if I knew my car
was gonna blow its front right tire
coming over the overpass today on the
way into town I could spend an hour
before I got in the car this morning
reading about what do you
when a front right tire blows did de sel
do I break is at four-wheel-drive - or
Drive front wheel rear wheel is there a
margin over there do I have a jack in
the trunk do I have a spare tire with
air in it if you did all that before
then the blowing of the tire doesn't
change but your reaction is completely
different and so I think stress is just
your body telling you you're not ready
and so change your readiness use the
time available to prepare yourself
better for the things that you are going
to have to do in your life I think you
enjoy life more if you just deliberately
do that
[Music]